question number one I call Douglas Ross
thank you very much presiding officer as
the month of Ramadan begins can I take
this opportunity to wish all Muslims in
Scotland and across the UK a very
peaceful holy month
the first Minister's party said this
when asked by journalists just last
month if they had lost 30 000 members
as the SMP clearly stated Quinn asked
fewer than 300 members have left the
party over the period
the court continued this story is both
malicious and wholly inaccurate
fortunately few people are gullible
enough
to believe it
since emerged that the story is 100
correct
so why did Nicholas sturgeon's party the
party of government in this Parliament
lie to the press and the public
on matters for which the government has
General responsibility first Minister
uh presiding officer can I begin by
uh wishing Ramadan Mubarak to our Muslim
Community I think I um in a very
privileged position of having of any
constituency in the country the highest
proportion of Muslims living within my
Glasgow Southside constituency I know
the holy month of Ramadan is a very
special time for Muslims and I wish them
all the best during it
um on the issue of SNP members that
issue has been well canvassed over the
last few days I've got nothing to add to
what I have already said except this
presiding officer the SNP Remains the
only Mass membership party in this
country
yeah
we have by far
more members than any other party
represented in this chamber and I think
presiding officer I can't say with some
confidence that the SNP has more members
than all other parties in this chamber
combined however I can't say that with
absolute certainty so let me say this
finally to Douglas Ross if he wants a
conversation a debate an interaction
about party membership figures then that
surely should be a meaningful one where
we can compare and contrast so before we
go any further will Douglas Ross share
with the chamber how many members his
party has
I thought it's it's pretty interesting
that the first Minister thank you
members
excuse me we will hear Mr Ross it's very
interesting that the first minister
speaks about confidence in numbers
because those seeking to replace her had
no confidence in the numbers her party's
chief executive and her head
Communications issued to the press and
this is an important issue here in the
Scottish Parliament this is an important
issue here in the Scottish Parliament
Excuse Me Miss Mr Ross
um Mr Ross is seeking to ask a question
of the first Minister can we please do
Mr Ross the courtesy of listening thank
you Mr Ross and and this is an important
issue here in the Scottish Parliament
for the Scottish government
they lied to
clear and Nicola sturgeon is cheating
the Scottish public list with this
embarrassing defense Mr Ross if I could
just remind you of the requirement of
all members to treat one another with
courtesy and respect at all times and
and before not only I but my
predecessors those who have um
you know sat in this chair before me
have said with regards to the use of
particular language in the chamber but I
think everyone has accepted that the SMP
lied over these figures and the defense
the defense from Nicholas sturgeon this
is embarrassing the
yeah the SMP and their story went on
like this they said you don't have
points of order you don't have points of
order during first ministers questions
the SMP said the story
[Applause]
first of all I will decide when we are
in our not
however
[Applause]
as is established convention I will not
be taking a point of order until the end
of this session Mr Ross well they don't
seem to want to hear this and I wonder
why a presiding officer because the smps
stood on these figures continued that
the the impression in the media was flat
wrong it was malicious and wholly
inaccurate they went on to say nobody
was gullible enough to believe the
reported reduction of 30 000 SMP members
but the truth is the SMP the SNP is a
party did lie that's why their chief
executive and the head of communications
has resigned so why would anybody be
gullible enough to believe that Nicolas
sturgeon was unaware of what her chief
executive and the most senior members of
our own party were up to
before the fresh Minister begins I will
remind all members of the requirement in
this chamber we do not use the word lie
in this chamber first minister
setting officer I think the only
character that is being revealed in this
chamber today is that of Douglas Ross
no
Douglas raw says leader of the
opposition no doubt going to be a very
long-standing leader of the opposition
well unless his party is something to
say about that he chooses the topics
that he raises and that is absolutely
right and proper but let it be noted uh
today for the people watching right now
that on this my last appearance as first
Minister first Minister's questions
Douglas Ross is not asking me about the
National Health Service or education or
the economy or climate Justice it but
this is the topic he has chosen party
membership figures so that is fine
have a proper interaction
a proper I don't think conservatives
given yesterday's events in the House of
Commons should be lecturing anyone about
honesty and integrity
we're coming back to saving officers
membership figures then before we go any
further perhaps Douglas Ross would
answer the question that I posed last
time and that we're still waiting for an
answer on how many members does the
Scottish conservative party have surely
he knows tell us
[Applause]
when you're on the back benches you get
to ask the questions at fmqs and your
final one you're supposed to answer now
the first ministers farewell tour this
week has been a master class in deceit
and political spin she was too busy far
too busy to appear in front of the
scored Affairs select committee but
somehow somehow managed to eat up Eco
time in her schedule to sit down and
lose women to debate the great officers
of state and the matters of state with
Janet Street Porter she says her party
is experiencing Growing Pains this must
be the first time that Growing Pains
have actually shrunk something she
claims that she's left her successor a
brilliant Foundation First Minister
that's all that's left that's the
foundation the house that sturgeon
salmon and moral
sorry I'm finding it very difficult to
hear you from here I would be grateful
if we could hear one member at a time
and only those members who I've called
Mr Ross I was just saying how the first
Minister claimed to have left her
successor with the brilliant Foundation
but that's all that's left the
foundation the house that sturgeon
salmon and moral built is collapsing and
the SNP have said it themselves party
president Mike Russell admitted this
week they are in a tremendous mess first
Minister he's right isn't he
first Minister well first lady once he
wants to know about collapsing at
political parties he should look at a
poll about leaders favorability ratings
published this very morning it does not
make happy reading for Douglas Ross but
on the issue of priorities uh presiding
officer and these are not the issues I
would have chosen to go on today but
Douglas Ross has chosen them so if he
wants to talk about priorities let me
point out that I am not the member of
this Parliament that missed a veterans
event to referee a football match
thank you
exactly on that point crusading officer
I am not accountable to the House of
Commons I am accountable to this
I know Douglas Ross has difficulty
deciding which Parliament is more
important to Scotland because he's got
one foot in each but I know which
Parliament is most important to Scotland
and it is this one our Scottish
Parliament
I'm finally presenting officer I am
proud
I am proud of the record of the
government I have laid through some of
the toughest times Scotland has faced in
recent history but ultimately the only
people who will cast a verdict on the
record of my or future government are
the people of Scotland and in my time as
first minister they have had eight
opportunities to do that and on each of
these eight opportunities they have
voted for me for the SNP and for my
government that's a record I'm very
proud to stand on
Douglas Rose
well let's see first of her record in
government
if the first minister is proud of her
record in government let's just look at
it in her final FM cues let's just go
over it or Nicholas sturgeon's watch
we will hear Mr Ross thank you on
Nicholas sturgeon's watch Scotland
schools have plummeted down
International League tables she has made
no progress on the attainment Gap and
broke her promise to close it completely
the name persons act the hate climact
the gender recognition Bill were all
unworkable
drug deaths in Scotland are the highest
in Europe five times greater than
anywhere else in the United Kingdom and
right now at this moment one in seven
Scots is on an NHS waiting list and on
her final day in this chamber as first
Minister it a cross-party committee of
this Parliament delivered a damning
report on ferries they found that
Nicholas sturgeon personally intervened
to prioritize vanity over vessels
leading to huge delays and costing the
taxpayers hundreds of millions of pounds
on these and so many other issues
Nicholas surgeon ignores Scotland's
priorities in favor of her obsession
with Independence she divided our
country and field on every Mission she
set herself first Minister isn't that
the truth of your legacy first Minister
presenting officer for Douglas Ross that
has not been at any point in
my first Minister the verdict of the
Scottish people eight election victories
in eight years as first Minister that's
the verdict that matters to me
but let's look at my records as first
Minister progressive income tax the
Scottish child payment lifting children
out of poverty the baby box closing the
attainment Gap record numbers of people
like from backgrounds like mine going to
University a national Investment Bank
leading the way in climate change
abolishing prescription charges minimum
unit pricing saving lives record high
Health funding the best performing
accident emergency departments anywhere
in the UK The Domestic Abuse Act free
period products expanded doubled Child
Care the promise for care experience two
young people the highest level of school
spend per people anywhere in the UK the
highest number of teachers per head
eight percent more teachers and now than
when I became first Minister free
tuition out for hire education free bus
travel for those under 22 I could go on
and on and on but I'm not going to
because this is my last session of first
ministers questions
question number two anasawa
thank you
can I join others in saying Ramadan
Mubarak it's a month of sacrifice of
reflection and charity and we remember
those that are less fortunate both here
at home and around the world
so we live in serious times with the
cost of living crisis and an NHS crisis
and given this is my last opportunity to
question the first Minister I do want to
ask about the finishing touches so I'm
sure it'll be a Handover document for
her successor and I think it's important
to check what she believes is in the
entry for the next first Minister
because after 15 years of SMP government
there is not a single Scottish
institution that is stronger now than
when her party took office from the
fairy Scandal the entrenched attainment
Gap the NHS crisis to decimated local
Services which of our government's many
failures does the first Minister think
her successor needs to address first
first Minister well with this is just
wrong I mean let's look first of all
some of the institutions that didn't
even exist when I became first Minister
uh Revenue Scotland for example making
sure that we have the most progressive
income tax system anywhere in the UK
Social Security Scotland delivering
benefits to people across the country
including the Scottish child payment the
Scottish national Investment Bank at
leading this country's drive now to Net
Zero the NHS of course facing real
challenges as a result of the coveted
pandemic but still with the best
performing any departments anywhere in
the UK tomorrow I will be in Fife
opening our new National Treatment
Center there that will deliver more
operations for people in Fife and will
soon be joined by national treatment
centers elsewhere across Scotland in
education more young people from the
kind of background like mine going to
University than has ever been the case
before a doubling of early years
education in child care I think that is
strengthening of many many institutions
does my successor have a tough job of
course because we live in tough times
but I've Got Confidence that whoever at
my successor turns out to be whoever is
standing here next week they will
continue to build on that record and
they will continue to retain the trust
of the Scottish people
can try and take credit for lots of
things I'm not sure she can take credit
for creating the National Health Service
I think that might have been a previous
government
Nicola sturgeon likes to talk about
records here are just a few set in hard
time piling up in her successor's Sky
High entry record any waiting times but
one in seven Scots on an NHS waiting
list record drug deaths record vacancies
for nurses and doctors in our NHS record
levels of children without a home record
levels of homelessness I could go on and
on but seeing it as our last first
Minister's questions I won't do that
it's hard to see how our successor will
be able to fix these problems as they
were sat around the cabinet table with
her the decisions taken around that
cabinet table resulted in over 3 billion
pounds of taxpayers money wasted since
2007. that's 1200 pound for every
household in Scotland and at the same
time they spent public money to build a
culture of cover-up and secrecy which is
now beginning to unravel all while Scott
struggled to keep their head above the
water line and given the scale of
challenges piled up in this entry does
the first Minister agree with two of the
three SMP candidates the mediocrity
continuity and incompetence won't cut it
first Minister well especially presiding
officer um I never claimed to have
created the National Health Service but
what I will what I will claim to have
done is help protect the founding
principles of Our National Health
Service because I was a health secretary
that abolished prescription charges for
everyone in Scotland something that in
all their years in government labor had
never ever got round to doing
I also took a hospital I also took a
hospital privatized under labor back in
to the National Health Service
[Applause]
three billion pounds figure I think
we've already shown that in previous
sessions it offers ministers questions
to be utterly nonsense but I'm not going
to embarrass them by going back to the
detail of that again today let me use
another
three billion pounds figure because that
is the number for the amount of money
this government is investing each year
to mitigate the cost of living crisis to
help people deal with Tory austerity if
we were an independent country we
wouldn't have to mitigate Tori austerity
but while labor still prefers to see
this country governed by Tories at
Westminster rather than have
self-governance and Independence here in
our own Parliament labor will never ever
be taken seriously in Scotland
and a solar
I like many people run across the United
Kingdom look forward to the next general
election where we can boot out the Tory
government and we can get rid of the
last SMP excuse
now the first Minister has spent much of
our political career talking about
mandates her successor inherits this
woeful SMP record but they don't inherit
her mandate the last election was a
pandemic election one in which the first
Minister one with a direct appeal from
heart to steer the country through the
pandemic and the covert recovery that
recovery hasn't even started in fact by
every metric things have got worse and
now Scotland faces two crises and NHS
recovery that never began and the cost
of living crisis families face inspiring
bills and soaring Energy prices but as
her potential successors Scrabble over
their own record in government they
can't escape facts they don't have a
plan for Scotland and they don't have a
mandate from the public and that is why
we need an election now
so in my final question to Nicholas
surgeon does she agree with her own
words
there are no words to describe this
utter shambles adequately it's beyond
Hyperbole and parody reality though is
the ordinary people are paying the price
the interests of the parties you concern
no one right now an election is now a
democratic imperative
thereward is I don't support a Tory
government of Scotland because Scotland
does not vote for conservatives and I I
fought three three general elections as
SNP leader and the SMP has won all of
them and everyone we've heard the same
messages from labor and every single one
the people of Scotland have cast their
verdict and I am proud of the
achievements of the governments that I
have led let me end on another one
because it is related to cover the
recovery and it has been achieved in
spite of what we're having to deal with
from the conservatives at Westminster
today Scotland has record high
employment record low unemployment and
record low economic inactivity we have a
good foundation in this country we Face
many challenges but I have every
confidence that my successor who will be
standing here next week will continue to
lead this country forward at will
continue to take the decisions that are
in the interest of this country and that
they will lead this country to becoming
an independent nation
number three Alex Paul Hamilton
thank you presiding officer and can I
also wish Ramadan Mubarak to everyone
celebrating you but also on this
national day of reflection and
commemoration remember more than 16 000
lives lost to us and the gaps they leave
in their communities and their families
as a result of the coveted pandemic she
may not know the answer to this but to
ask the first Minister when the cabinet
will next meet first Minister and that
of course is a matter for the new first
Minister the only thing I know for
certain is that I will not be in
attendance
um can I say though presenting officer
now I will say more about this in the
the session that follows fnqs today of
course March the third anniversary of
lockdown and my thoughts today as my
thoughts are at some stage in every
single day with all those who suffered
as a result of covet I will have them in
my thoughts my mind and my heart for as
long as I live
Alex call Hamilton I'm very grateful for
that reply and I share its sentiments
the mental health treatment targets were
introduced in December 2014 11 days
after Nicholas sturgeon was sworn in as
first minister they have never been met
not once in over 3 000 days that's 99
consecutive months I have lost count of
the number of times that the first
Minister told me that the situation was
unacceptable I have lost count of the
number of times she promised staff and
sufferers that things would get better
but in reality Nicholas sturgeon quietly
downgraded the office of mental health
Minister her finance department headed
by Cape Forbes slashed 50 million pounds
from the mental health budget this
winter and her health secretary Hamza
Yusuf gave a personal promise to clear
waiting list for both children and
adults by March 2023 presiding officer
look at the calendar it's March we are
here and the SNP are nowhere there is a
sea of human pain out there so much
unmet need don't just tell me that this
is unacceptable at this late hour at the
last and final time of asking will the
first Minister admit her government has
failed Scotland on Mental Health First
Minister what I will absolutely see is
there is much much more work to do on
Mental Health one of the things that has
changed certainly since I was a young
person and has changed even in the years
I've been first minister is that we have
reduced the stigma associated with
mental health more people are coming
forward for help and treatment and that
is a good thing but we must make sure
the services are there for them we have
seen a significant increase in the
budget for mental health under the SNP
mental health spending has doubled in
cash terms we see many more people
working in mental health services and
was previously the case come coming
directly to cams because it is important
and there is so much more to do the
number of children starting a treatment
for cams in the most recent quarter is
the highest on record by some distance
and we're now seeing the most sustained
changes in Cam's waiting list for over
half a decade the overall waiting list
has decreased by more than nine percent
children waiting over 18 weeks has
decreased by more than 30 percent and
children waiting over 52 weeks has
decreased by more than 48 so yes much
much more to do but progress at being
made and I know it will be a priority
for my successor whoever he or she may
be to continue that progress
question number four Fiona Hislop
to ask the first Minister for a response
to the intergovernmental panel on
climate changes synthesis report
first Minister the evidence has never
been clearer than it is now we are first
running out of time to secure a livable
and a sustainable future for the
generations to come this report must
lead to an acceleration of global action
to tackle the climate emergency Scotland
is making long-term progress towards net
zero but we are now entering the most
challenging part of that Journey
requiring truly transformational action
across society and our economy this
cannot and will not happen without all
of us including everyone across this
Parliament supporting bold steps as part
of a national effort to tackle the
climate emergency lastly at Corp 27
Scotland pledged an additional 5 million
pounds to address loss and damage and we
will continue to advocate for practical
action and finance to support the global
South where the effects of climate
change are already being experienced
Fiona has what following the publication
of this report U.N Secretary General
Antonio Gutierrez made a plea to all
governments he said humanity is on the
nice and that ice is melting fast the
report is a Clarion call to massively
fast-track climate efforts by every
country and every sector and on every
time frame in short our world needs
climate action on all fronts everything
everywhere all at once I know how
serious and ambitious the first Minister
has been in leading on the climate
emergency agenda and I appreciate that
does she agree that this Stark
assessment must lead to transformational
and accelerated action by all
governments local government the UK
government and her successor here in
this Parliament to combat climate change
first Minister I agree wholeheartedly
with Euro Hislop and I agree
wholeheartedly with the comments earlier
this week of the United Nations
Secretary General there's no doubt that
we need a concerted action accelerated
action on all fronts I'm proud that
Scotland is and we are recognized as
being at the Forefront of the group
journey to reach net zero emissions and
a climate resilient future at this
parliament's ambitious climate change
legislation requires all of us
governments individuals communities and
businesses to take lasting action to
drive down our emissions in a way that
is just in fear for all but we also need
to see action and much higher ambition
from the UK government on the solutions
for Net Zero that are currently reserved
to Westminster and of course we need
other countries across the world to
match that Ambitions to well Scotland's
emissions reduction targets are in line
with a global 1.5 pathway it's vital
that other countries revisit and and
strengthen the ambition of their 2030
emissions pledges and long-term
strategies to align with our 1.5 pathway
ahead of Corp 28. William Kerr
very grateful presiding officer the ipcc
report
we also spend business
foreign
okay thank you we will resume business
and I would ask Liam Kerr to begin his
question thank you very grateful
presiding officer the ipcc report made
start warnings about how if we'd have
any hope of tackling the climate
emergency we must look at all green
generation Technologies now given that
countries such as Japan Germany and
France are swinging behind nuclear
generated energy which is a zero
emission clean energy source isn't it
now imperative that the first Minister's
government looks again with an
evidence-based and a science-led
assessment at its knee-jerk Banning of
new nuclear in Scotland first Minister
okay
firstly again with the sentiment behind
that question we all have to up our
action on this and green energy
generation is a vital part of it but but
I don't agree on the question of nuclear
nuclear energy is very expensive we
still don't know what to do with the
waste long term and of course not all
other countries have Scotland's offshore
wind potential for example between
hydrogen potential and other renewable
sources of energy potential you know
Scotland right now it gives us the
potential to generate up to 28 gigawatts
of renewable energy that is massive that
will enable us to export as well as meet
our own needs so I think we should focus
on renewable clean green renewable
energy that's not just right for the
environment that gives us the
opportunity to boost industry the
economy and create tens of thousands of
jobs in the future that's where the
focus of this and future Scottish
government should be Colin Smith
this report is the starkist one and yet
that will our world leaders fiddle the
world bonds and we're not on track the
whole global warming at 1.5 degrees but
there's a first Minister except that she
leaves office Scotland is also failing
to meet her climate targets there's a
climate change committee one Scotland is
missing so many of those targets are in
danger of becoming meaningless now given
that transport Remains the biggest
source of emissions does the first
Minister regret the Savage Cuts made to
a real and bus services on her watch
mean or the dipping cardio since 2016 is
12.5 the collapse in rail numbers is
over 50 and bus passenger numbers is
over 40 and does she agree it is a
priority for her successor to reverse
the cuts that she made to those Services
first Minister well no I don't regret
public ownership of a Railways I don't
regret the changes to bus franchising
and I certainly don't regret the free
bus travel for pensioners and all young
people under 22 encouraging people to
use public transport but I do agree
I do agree that Scotland like all other
countries must do more Scotland is doing
it more to cut emissions and to tackle
climate change than almost any other
country in the world I've been
privileged to attempt to attend Co-op
climate change at Summits over many
years now and there is a recognition for
Scotland's leadership if not here in
this Parliament then certainly amongst
countries overseas but the bar of world
leadership is too low every country
needs to do more and we need to do it
with urgency and Scotland must continue
to lead by example Mark Roscoe
thank you this report is also a reminder
that extracting every last drop of oil
and gas today will condemn future
generations to climate breakdown
independent research commissioned
through the Butte house agreement has
shown that North Sea oil and gas output
will continue to fall while a just
transition can deliver an increase in
jobs in the years ahead so can I ask the
first Minister what kind of leadership
do we need from the Scottish government
to ensure a future for both workers and
the climate
I think we need to continue at the kind
of leadership that we have been showing
on this issue I'm very clear while I
have the greatest respect for all those
who work in oil and gas sector they have
contributed hugely to Scotland and we
cannot make that switch overnight we
must accelerate the transition from
fossil fuels to renewable energy and as
Martin Russell rightly says even if we
weren't facing the climate emergency the
maturity of the North Sea would mean
that we have to accelerate that
transition there we must do it in a fair
and a just way and but we have the
potential to do that and we should grab
that potential with both hands question
number five Stephen Kerr ask the first
Minister what the outcomes have been of
the Scottish government's defining
mission to tackle the poverty related
attainment Gap first Minister well this
government's commitment is to
substantially eliminate the poverty
related attainment Gap in this
parliamentary term and good progress is
being made the latest achievement of
curriculum for excellence levels data
demonstrated the biggest single year
decrease in the poverty related Gap in
primary numeracy and literacy levels
since records began we are improving
outcomes for young people impacted by
poverty Beyond School two the percentage
of 2021-22 school leavers in a positive
initial destination is the highest on
record and the poverty related
attainment Gap is at a record low down
two-thirds since 2019. more young people
than ever from deprived communities
secured a place at University and the
previous commissioner for widening
access described our approach as an
unambiguous success training officer
that is a record I am proud of and I
very much look forward to seeing my
successor build on it
objectively the best we can say is the
first Minister tried and failed because
education in Scotland is poorer here's
her record fewer maths teachers fewer
technical education teachers fewer
Computing science teachers fewer
language teachers narrowing subject
Choice plummeted during the
international league tables and on CFE
levels in primary schools literacy
falling breathing falling writing
falling numerously falling a whitening
attainment Gap and falling attainment
overall can she honestly stand there
hand on heart and say the education was
our top priority
sir
about outcomes I'm just checking that
that was the word in this question so I
gave him the data on the outcomes and he
obviously didn't like it so he wants to
talk about input so let me talk now
about inputs and when I became first
Minister the number of school teachers
in Scotland was 49
521 today the number of school teachers
in Scotland is 53
459 and eight percent increase
in early learning in child care settings
the numbers have increased as well in
Scotland we have the most teachers per
pupil in the UK and education spend per
person is higher than in either England
and Wales in Scotland we have 7
573 teachers per 100 000 pupils in
England where the Tories are in power
that is just 5734.
in Scotland we spend 7 600 pounds per
pupil the Tories in England spend just
six thousand seven hundred yes I am
proud of this government's record on
education and I really do look forward
to seeing it being built upon
Paul McLennan
thank you presenting officer at the
recent Institute of fiscal studies
analysis of Scottish tax and benefit
reform founded at lowest income families
in Scotland are significantly better off
around 2 000 pounds on average as a
result of this SMP scores government's
place of aggressive tax and benefit
policies but this can be achieved with
limited powers how much further does a
first Minister think we go if we were
holding to UK government with policies
that directly directly undermine this
government's mission to tackle poverty
first Minister now I thank Paul McLean
and for that question and again and this
may be the last opportunity I have to
point it out it is really obvious how
uncomfortable the conservatives become
in this chamber when we are talking
about poverty and I think that should be
noted
The Institute for fiscal studies rightly
acknowledges the impact that Progressive
choices are having for low-income
families they highlight and I'm going to
quote briefly presiding officer that the
Scottish government have made clearly a
distributional choice to Channel A lot
more money towards low-income families
with children in particular and that has
a meaningful impact on incomes if I had
to single out the thing I was proudest
of it is that helping lift children out
of poverty in Mark contrast to the
approach of the UK government's welfare
system where they push children into
poverty that's the difference that's the
contrast
question number six Jackie Bailey
to ask the first Minister what action
the Scottish government is taking to
tackle the reportedly high levels of
delayed discharge which are estimated to
have cost over 161 million pounds in 22
23 to date first Minister earlier this
year we allocated an additional 8
million pounds to support Health and
Social care Partnerships to secure extra
provision of 300 interim Care Home beds
today this has enabled 408 people to be
discharged from hospitals to these
placements with a total of 633 people
currently benefiting from an interim
care placement as part of the work of
the ministerial Advisory Group and
Health and Social care pressures we
continue to work tirelessly with health
boards and Health and Social care
Partnerships to ensure we are doing
everything possible to support people
out of acute settings and back into the
community when it's clinically safe to
do so delayed discharge has improved
substantially under this government and
it is of course very welcome the over 96
percent of all people overall leaving
hospital are discharged without any
leave whatsoever Jackie Bailey can I
thank the first Minister for her
response since she took office over a
billion pounds has been lost to delayed
discharge at her very first fmqs I
raised cancer treatment delays in 2014
94.2 percent of patients started cancer
treatment within 62 days with a maximum
weight of 187 days this is now declined
to 74 percent of patients starting
treatment within 62 days and a maximum
weight of 326 days the 31 and 62-day
cancer treatment targets are at their
worst ever when the first Minister
entered Butte house 148 patients waited
over 12 hours in a e now it's 6600.
3118 people were on waiting lists now
it's seven thousand seven hundred and
sorry seven thousand seven hundred there
were six thousand two hundred children
waiting for access to Mental Health
Services now it's over seven thousand
five hundred nurse vacancies have risen
from two thousand to almost six thousand
and in 2014 there were just 15 excess
deaths now they're almost four thousand
life expectancies
gone backwards on her watch and that is
shameful and as if that wasn't bad
enough the first Minister gave us Hamza
uses we must have a question since
Devolution let me make one final plea to
the first Minister she gave a commitment
she gave her commitment two weeks ago to
look into the case of nine-year-old
Harvey Martin who has scoliosis and
urgently requires surgery desperate for
help Harvey sent the first Minister a
video message and she has not yet
replied so before the first Minister
leaves office will she reply to Harvey
and help him get the surgery he so
desperately needs first Minister well
firstly saving officer let me address at
the case of young Harvey Martin because
I have been taking time rightly this
week to check with NHS law then about
his case and I can confirm that Harvey
will be given a date for his procedure
very soon and NHS law they will be
discussing the date with his parents
when they speak next week and I wish
young Harvey all the very best on cancer
waiting times more patients have been
treated on both the 62 and 31-day
Pathways in this latest quarter compared
to the previous quarter it compared to
the same time last year and indeed
compared to the last full quarter
pre-pandemic more to do but progress
being made of course Jackie Bailey's
question was about delay discharge and
I'm going to therefore end on that tip
before I do let me reflect on the fact
that Jackie Bailey asked me my very
first question as first Minister and she
is today asking me if not the last
question then the last scheduled
question on the order paper of course
when she asked me my first question she
was standing over there as the principal
opposition Representatives now she is
over there that says
that says a great deal about the verdict
of the Scottish people in the
intervening periods presiding officer
and of course I'm still standing here
which also says a lot about the verdict
of the Scottish people but finally
Jackie Bailey likes to do comparisons so
finally on delayed discharges today
there are around 1700 patients classed
as delayed discharge that is far too
many but to be clear today that includes
everybody delayed for any period of time
even an hour when Jackie Bailey was a
minister when her party was on this side
of the chamber there were 2 200 patients
delayed for more than six weeks in our
National Health Service that represented
more than 70 percent more than 70
percent of all patients ready for
discharge were delayed for more than six
weeks when Jackie Bailey was last in
government today
96 of patients are delayed with no delay
are discharged with no delay whatsoever
more to do presiding officer but so much
more about some much progress made since
Jackie Bailey and her party were in
office
that concludes first Minister's
questions
the next item of business is a personal
statement by the first Minister and
today marked the final contribution in
this chamber of Nicholas sturgeon MSP as
first Minister our longest serving first
Minister and the first woman to hold the
post and on behalf of the parliament I
thank the first Minister for her service
I thank John Swinney MSP the deputy
first Minister for his service too they
have both been in government since 2007
and I wish them well for the future
I know colon Nicholas sturgeon first
minister
thank you presenting officer and uh
thank you for your kind words I'm sure I
speak on behalf of the Deputy first
minister in expressing that gratitude I
have indeed just concluded my
286 and final session of first
Minister's questions and this is the
final statement I will make in this
chamber as first minister
no matter what I do in future nothing
absolutely nothing will come close to
the experience of the past
3046 days
being first minister of the country I
love has been a profound owner I have
led Scotland through good times but also
through the toughest period of a recent
history
exactly three years ago today I stood at
a podium in Saint Andrew's house and I
asked the country to stay at home
my thoughts today and always with those
who lost loved ones to covet those who
live still with long covet with our
young people who lost out on so many of
the normal experiences of growing up
and with everyone who endured the trauma
of separation and loneliness
covet shaped all of us
I know that it changed me and in many
ways it defined my time as first
minister
above all it reinforced in me an abiding
admiration for the people of this
wonderful country who made such painful
sacrifices to keep each other safe
in the toughest of times our country
showed the best of itself with love care
and solidarity and that will live with
me forever
being first Minister has been variously
often all at once challenging
exhilarating and exhausting
but every single day without exception
it has been an utter privilege
I have set out already my reasons for
stepping down now I won't repeat them
today
suffice to say I know in my heart that
this is the right time
after more than 35 years in politics 24
years in this Parliament 16 years in
government and more than eight years as
first Minister it is time for Nicola
sturgeon the politician to make a bit of
space for Nicole sturgeon the person
it's time for me to contribute in a
different capacity to the causes I care
so deeply about gender equality care
experience young people climate Justice
and always until the job is done winning
Scottish independence
and no matter how difficult change maybe
I know also that it is right for my
party the government and our country
that I now meet way for a new generation
of leadership
I have made my fair share of mistakes in
the past eight years and of course there
are things I wish I had done better or
differently
but overall and overwhelmingly I am
proud of what has been achieved
the doubling of early years education
and child care the Scottish child
payment widening access to higher
education with a record number of young
people from backgrounds like mine now
going to University minimum unit pricing
a policy that is saving lives a publicly
owned mission-driven National Investment
Bank and putting the climate emergency
at the heart of all we do
just a few of the many policies that I
believe will have a lasting impact on
our country
as the first woman to hold this office
advancing gender equality has also been
very close to my heart my cabinet has
always been gender balanced this
Parliament legislated for free period
products and strengthened the law on
domestic abuse
unless tangibly perhaps but just as
important no girl in our country now has
any doubt that a woman can hold the
highest office in the land I heard a
phrase the other day that really struck
a chord with me
when women lift girls rise
I've tried this first minister to put
that into practice and I will continue
to do so for the rest of my life
writing officer there are countless
people who have supported me along the
way today I want to see a heartfelt
thank you to just some of them
firstly to my family
nothing absolutely nothing would be
possible without the love and support
you give me daily
to my extended family the SNP
the party I joined at 16 when on a good
day we would hit 12 in the opinion polls
we've come such a long way together as a
team let us keep going serving Scotland
together as a team
to my colleagues here in Hollywood in
SNP parliamentary groups past and
present and to the central office staff
who support us
to all of my ministerial colleagues over
the years
and especially to John Swinney the best
Deputy first Minister and the best
friend I could have wished for on this
journey
to our staff and party HQ who have built
a formidable campaign operation enabling
us to win 14 national elections since
2007. to all those who have worked in my
constituency office in particular to my
current team Paul Leinster Caroline
Scott Mary Hunter Carolyn mcconville
Irfan Rabbani and Nikita Bassey you have
had my back throughout and you work
tirelessly every single day to help me
represent the people of Glasgow South
Side
and to my constituency party and to my
constituents thank you so much for
putting your trust in me time and again
to my special advisors you have given
your all to me and to the cause of
building a better country you've been
led by two outstanding Chiefs of Staff
Liz Lloyd and Colin McAllister
to our partners in the Scottish green
party I am very proud of the boot house
agreement thank you for joining us in
government
and to our brilliant Civil Service
Scotland is so fortunate in the
Integrity impartiality and
professionalism of our civil servants
and I am privileged to have been served
by some of the very best I thank each
and every one but let me make special
mention of those who have served in my
policy unit and in my fmq team
the latter especially on Wednesday
evenings and Thursday mornings really do
have the worst job in government
for the avoidance of Doubt presiding
officer the good answers have always
been down to them the bad have been all
me
finally I want to thank from the bottom
of my heart three groups of people who
because of the nature of the jobs they
do have probably spent more time with me
over these years than with their
families at least I'm sure that is how
it has felt so to my security team thank
you for keeping me safe
to the wonderful boot house staff thank
you for always making me feel at home
and to every private secretary Dairy
secretary correspondent secretary to the
visits and events team to the
communications and Camera teams to
everyone in my private office who has
supported me over 16 years in government
thank you for keeping me going
obviously I can't name everyone as much
as I'd love to but there are a few I do
want to mention
my longest serving principal private
secretary John Summers and the current
incumbent Chris Mackey
and last but not least three very
special people who individually and
collectively have been with me for
almost all of my time as first minister
see people who are the core of my team
during covet coming into the office
While others stayed at home to give me
the support I needed to do my job
Nicola Dove Patrick crowler and Gary
McGee
you three will never know how much your
care kindness and humor have sustained
me over these years and I am so going to
miss you
planning officer as I come to the end of
my last speech here as first Minister
some final reflections
to you
I am sure you're hoping for a new first
Minister whose answers on a Thursday
lunch time are not quite as long-winded
as mine
thank you for your patience
to my colleagues across this chamber
robust debate and holding government to
account are the Hallmarks of what we do
in here that is as it should be and let
me thank those in other parties for that
but maybe just maybe we might
actually enhance our democracy
have occasionally we all of us treated
each other with kindness too if we
remembered that we are opponent not
enemies
and to my successor next week we will
find out whose portrait will go
alongside mine on the stairwell of boot
house
subject to this chamber's approval it
will either be Scotland's second female
first minister or the first from a
minority ethnic background
either way that will say hint the very
powerful message that this the highest
office in the land is one that any young
person in Scotland can aspire to
never forget that every day in this
office is an opportunity
to make something better for someone
somewhere in Scotland do not shy away
from the big challenges or difficult
debates
you won't get everything right but it is
always better to aim high and fall short
than not try at all
and always draw strength energy and
wisdom from the people of this wonderful
country
and as no to the people of Scotland all
of you whether you voted for me or not
that I reserve my final words from the
seat
thank you so much for placing your trust
in me
words will never
adequately convey the Gratitude and the
ore I hold in my heart
for the opportunity I have had to serve
as your first minister
it truly has been the privilege of my
lifetime and with these words presiding
officer I draw it to a close
thank you that concludes the statement
by the first Minister I will now call on
other members to respond and I call on
Douglas Ross thank you very much
presiding officer and well I believe the
first Minister and I see each other as
adversaries rather than allies and
probably the final session of fmqs
reiterated that impression uh let me add
a little balance in my final response
remarks to Nicholas surgeon as first
minister
when Nicholas sturgeon leaves office she
will bring to a close a political career
in this chamber the few if many can or
will match in its length 24 years of
service to our constituents so far
16 years as a government Minister and
over eight years as first minister
indeed since 1999 she has been a
permanent fixture in this Parliament and
on our party's front bench
in these times of political turbulence
that is steam power that many of us
could only ever wish for
she has been a formidable campaigner as
her political opponents over the years
can unanimously agree on
and no one can lie that Nicholas surgeon
has left for better or worse a mark on
our country
we have all lived through the sturgeon
era of Scottish politics and that era is
now coming
to an end
a new here will that change be felt more
keenly than within the ranks of her own
party
but returning to the government rule and
as first Minister for Nicholas sturgeon
and her predecessors and successors it
Remains the greatest of honors
and even reader still for Port Nicholas
sturgeon described herself as a
working-class girl from Ayrshire
I recognize the positive message it
sends that in Scotland every child
should have the ability to reach the
heights that they'd dream of
and you know what signing officer
sometimes dreams do come true I stand
here in this chamber
as the only recent politician to beat
Nicholas sturgeon
I won the bet the bet I had with nickel
sturgeon made back in 2021 a hundred
pounds and I won that just for the
record I have to say that I'm still
awaiting payment and and and it is
perhaps one final example of delays from
Nicholas sturgeon's government
but I mean in all sincerity that the
exchanges that we have uh you know have
been uh sometimes difficult always
robust
um and we seek to do better in our
politics and I think the message the
first Minister had can be listened by
everyone in this chamber
and the first Minister has also spoken
of the additional responsibility that
she has had and she said this in the
past to help every woman and girl in our
country fulfill their own potential
and I think that as the first woman
holder of her office she has been a role
model that women and girls can aspire to
in Scotland today
these are all achievements for which the
first Minister should be rightly proud
yeah well the first minister is a
talented politician those talents have
not always been used to the best of
their ability in government I'm not
going to use this session to labor over
the arguments that we've had on this
side of the chamber time and time again
I simply see this that on her first day
in office Nicholas sturgeon promised to
be the first Minister for all of
Scotland regardless of your politics or
your point of view
but for some too often she used her
position to further her party's
political objectives rather than bring
the country together and govern in all
of Scotland's interests
however I accept
that holding the high office is a great
burden and honor and I think it is right
that on this day of all days we
acknowledge the difficult
responsibilities that the covid pandemic
placed upon those in power and along
with the first Minister and others that
I put on record our thoughts on this
side of the chamber for everyone who
sadly lost their lives and those who
continue to mourn the loss of loved ones
as I said earlier there's no secret that
the first Minister and I are not best
friends and I'm sure she won't miss our
weekly fnq exchanges as she watches on
from the back benches in my time as
leader of the opposition I've asked
Nicholas surgeon 256 questions once or
twice I've even got an answer
but away from this chamber I know that
political leadership also takes a
personal toll on those who attain the
highest office and it takes a toll on
those closest to them as well I think we
could all see that the thanks that the
first Minister gave to her family and
her staff were difficult for her to
articulate it but our keenly felt there
will have been countless times that the
first Minister will not been able to
have been there for her family and her
friends as she put the demands of
leadership first
so I hope that in standing down the
first Minister will be able to take
comfort from having more time for family
friends and of course her passion
reading
so on behalf of this side of the chamber
but we have passionately disagreed with
Nicholas sturgeon over the years and no
doubt will continue to do so into the
future we wish her well as she leaves
the office of first Minister and forever
the future holds for her
thank you I now call on Anna Star Wars
thank you training officer today is a
significant moment in Scottish politics
it of course has personal significance
for Nicholas sturgeon but is also
significant for our politics as Scotland
prepares to face a new era and a twin
crisis of the NHS crisis and the cost of
living crisis and I'd like to start by
placing on record my respect and
recognition for Nicola sturgeon more
than 20 years of public service and I
first met Nicholas surgeon when I was a
teenager and that's not meant as a
disparaging comment it's a compliment
and it's safe to say that both of us
have grown up and changed a lot since
then regardless of our many differences
even our harshest critics would accept
that Nicholas sturgeon is an able and
formidable politician who has stood at
the Forefront of Scottish politics for
more than 15 years and while we've
disagreed passionate about what is best
for the people I have never for a moment
doubted her love for Scotland
and seeing the first woman elected as
first Minister an achievement presiding
officer that cannot be understated was
an important moment for our country
it was assigned to women and girls
regardless of their politics that there
should be no limit to their ambition
that there was no position no office in
the land that they couldn't aspire to
and there was nothing that they should
not be able to achieve
now I'm sure many people will Point
towards our more robust exchanges
personal discussions but on many
occasions Nicholas George and I and I
have attempted to build consensus
particularly and calling out and
challenging the rising levels of
prejudice and hate in society and I
think this is in part driven by our deep
connection with the south side of
Glasgow something that the first
Minister herself referenced the most
diverse part of Scotland and I know how
much celebrating the rich diversity in
our communities means to her I would
even challenge perhaps maybe she's more
traditional Asian dress more often than
I have in my lifetime now there are many
things that we can disagree and divide
on but there is one issue which I
believe should always unite every
political party in this Parliament and
that is the fight against prejudice and
hate in a resignation statement last
month Nicholas Sergeant spoke about the
personal toll the politics takes and I
often reflect on how much our politics
has changed how much more divisive has
become how intolerant it can often be
and the challenge I think for all of us
is how we build the politics that of
course allows for strong disagreement
passionate debate robust arguments but
then there's that never descends into
hatred because far too often
particularly online our politics does
this end into that hatred
I'm a trading officer it's not by the
praise or the criticism of her opponents
that any first Minister will be judged
it will be their record and as first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon LED our
country through challenging times most
obviously during the pandemic and I
think she's right I think that is what
will Define her time and I recognize the
immense pressure and the toll many
decisions taken in those difficult years
will have taken at a time of uncertainty
and anxiety she attempted to provide
stability and reassurance to people
across this country at the darkest
moments
I think it's fair to say that during our
many robust debates with one another
I've learned some of Nicholas sturgeon's
tales and when her grasp of the detail
perhaps might on occasion Escape her
orange say orange
urgent on her side she is obviously
quick to point to her electoral record
we've heard again today eight election
wins of course undoubtedly a political
achievement to be proud of a legacy that
no one can deny and of course many of us
can be jealous off but she is right
winning is important winning does matter
and that's why it also matters that
leaders of whichever political party
what they do with that power when they
do when and how they govern and I think
it's also safe to say that never in the
history of devolution has there been a
first minister with so much power so
much time and so much political Capital
but despite that we all know there is
still so much more to do because
presenting officer the promise of
devolution does remain unfulfilled child
poverty is still too high NHS waiting
lists are still too long our public
services are struggling and our economy
does need to be restarted and we must
now urgently confront those challenges
and that must be this place is focused
so in closing I am sure this government
will fuel her absence from the front
benches perhaps no one no one as keenly
as our successor as our success Nicholas
surgeon leaves a government and a party
shaped In Her Image it will not find a
replacement like her I and my entire
party were sure the very best for
whatever she chooses to do in the future
thank you
thank you I now call on Patrick Harvey
thank you presiding officer I'm
privileged to be able to offer a few
comments from the Scottish green party
at this uh this moment and over the last
week while I've had both the first
Minister and the deputy first Minister
reflect on how they might have felt back
in their early days as teenage activists
if they had known the role they would go
on to play in providing the role of
leaders of government for Scotland
but my first memory of meeting Nicola
sturgeon years before I stood for
Parliament myself was when she was
providing opposition not government
and I'm sure there were times when
opposition meant saying no but in the
first year of this new Scottish
Parliament with the rights and equality
of a marginalized group on the line
Nicola starting recognized that when the
government does the right thing
the role of opposition involves being
constructive and in the the law most
often called section 28 it was a nasty
homophobic hangover of the 1980s and in
the first debate about repealing that
law
Nicola sturgeon said section 28 is
plainly and simply about discrimination
it is about singling out one section of
the population and labeling it as
unacceptable now she was not the only
politician saying so
but what she did helped to ensure that
that issue was not seen as Government
versus opposition
and that rival parties with serious
disagreements could work between them to
find the common ground and work together
for the good of the country
now I've agreed and disagreed with
Nicola sturgeon on issues over the years
since then but in recent months she has
shown that same commitment to stand by
another vulnerable group in our society
while so many in politics and in the
media were dredging up the tropes and
Prejudice of past decades and
redirecting them against transgender
people
so I can still see today
what I remember from those days Nicholas
dungeon's commitment to be an ally to
marginalized people remains part of her
character as a politician
now as I say I didn't know at that time
that I would go on to join the Scottish
Parliament or indeed that I would have
the chance to sit with Nicola sturgeon
on The Advisory board at the yes
Scotland campaign for Scottish
independence or even that I would share
the stage whether the Glasgow Hydro of
all places even if we did have to share
the bell with a certain Mr George
Galloway
I certainly couldn't have imagined that
she and John Sweeney would pick up the
phone and offer to negotiate an
agreement which would bring the greens
into government for the first time in
this country's history advancing action
on climate Justice and Progressive
values and in doing so infuriating right
Wingers vested interests polluting
Industries and even one or two of their
own back benches
so I also see today what I remember from
earlier days that Nicola sturgeon seized
the value in politicians and political
parties recognizing their differences
but seeking common ground and finding
ways to work together for the good of
the country
presiding officer on this day of
national National reflection we all
share the sentiment Nicola sturgeon
expressed a few minutes ago
and as for the things that her time as
first Minister will be remembered for
outside of the political bubble I think
for most people it will be her
leadership during a pandemic that
changed all of our lives
at the start as we were just coming to
terms with what the world was facing
some governments around the world chose
Bluff and Bluster pretending they knew
the answers or offering false Simplicity
in place of the complex truth Nicola
sturgeon made a braver choice to be
clear about what wasn't known
and to express the same fears and
uncertainty that we all felt throughout
the pandemic she not only fronted up the
Scottish government response on an
almost daily basis but she did so with
honesty Clarity and humility and by
doing that she earned the public Trust
so presiding officer whatever the future
brings I thank both Nicholas dungeon and
John Sweeney for their service to
Scotland I wish them very well and my
highest hope for them is that they
continue to find ways to infuriate all
the right people
thank you I now call on Alex Paul
Hamilton
thank you very much indeed presiding
officer um presiding officer those of us
who seek a life in public service must
deal with events and times as we find
them not as we would wish them to be
regardless of what circumstance throws
our way it is incumbent on all of us to
commit to the task before us to seek the
best for our communities and in so doing
try always to reflect the better Natures
of the people that we seek to serve as
the first woman to achieve this office
of first Minister Nicholas sturgeon has
provided inspiration to the women and
girls that will doubtless follow her to
this the highest office in the land she
has been in Scotland's first Minister
through some of the darkest hours in our
modern history I think it is important
to recognize her tireless and
substantial commitment to the office
that she has helped for longer than
anybody else and that tireless
commitment was no more evident than in
those the worst days of the pandemic a
time of unprecedented anxiety for our
country when she offered a voice of calm
to people stuck at home
she will be aware of the times that she
has walked in step with my party when
she adopted our policies on things like
child care and the pupil premium she
will recognize the times that when we
have voted with her sometimes against
the prevailing wind on the physical
punishment of children on alcohol
pricing on advancing the rights of
Scotland's LGBT plus Community she has
acknowledged some historic wrongs as
well like yesterday for the victims of
forced adoption
she knows my background and as such I
will always appreciate her dedication
her continuing dedication to Young Scots
currently in the care of this state or
who have experience of the Scottish care
system
presiding officer good and bad this
chamber will debate her Legacy long
after her departure
the first Minister and I are very
different people our visions of the
future of Scotland and of the United
Kingdom and Kingdom just do not align
but I recognize hard work when I see it
I am also grateful for the kindness that
she has done me personally on occasion
indeed the words of comfort she once
offered me in private conversation when
my daughter was hospitalized or
something I will not forget
the sons of Politics the Scottish
politics are now shifting in big and
unpredictable ways this is a moment it's
a Crossroads a chance to do things
differently and people are now looking
for inspiration people are looking for
New Hope
presenting officer I'd like to finish by
thanking Nicholas sturgeon and indeed
her Deputy John Swinney for both of
their service to our country and I wish
them well with whatever comes next thank
you
thank you I now call on emerodic
thank you presiding officer it is truly
an honor to be speaking today on the
resignation of the first Minister though
it is a decision that I and I think the
country are still needing to come to
terms with and when the first Minister
became the first Minister I was 17 and I
was in the audience at Eden Court where
she came to speak to voters and
activists about her plans for Scotland
and I'm going to come back to that
moment later but for now I'm going to
reflect on that plan for Scotland
because that plan is what brought us the
baby box it's what brought us the
Scottish child payment the promise all
emblematic of the progressive values
that the first Minister not only brought
to the fore of the SNP but brought so
many into the SMP on the back of now
stopped the world Scotland wants to get
on is rightfully a very famous campaign
line of winning earrings but Nicholas
sturgeon didn't wait for Independence to
bring it to life she has been an
ambassador for Scotland and that will
serve us well when her successors
deliver Independence
she's also always stayed true to herself
and as a young Survivor of sexual
assault this is the first Minister I
watched stand up not just when it was
easy or abstract but when it was
difficult and say women deserve justice
and I think we can also look at how
she's spent the last few weeks in her
role when people can't accuse her of it
being about keeping her position next
time or winning Applause she has tackled
misogyny she has delivered a very moving
apology for historic adoption practices
and of course spent time with the care
experienced young people of Scotland to
whom she was the first to say the state
does not just owe them a home we owe
them our love
and at a time that we were so isolated
so separate Nicholas surgeon was trusted
invited and welcomed into millions of
living rooms across the country now the
last time I was allowed to visit my
mother
um was before the last lockdown the
lockdown that she caught covered in and
we sat in her garden and she told me all
about what Nicola had said to her that
morning talking about the first minister
of Scotland like this was someone from
down the road who'd popped in for a
coffee and that's the kind of connection
that Nicola sturgeon has made with
people length and breadth of this
country
which brings me on to the second part of
her Legacy because it's not just the
policies that she put in place it is the
people she lifted as she climbed the
woman that she mentored inspired
empowered the people that she told their
passion their voluntary work their
opinions are politically valuable they'd
been disenfranchised and she brought
them in and gave them a voice and they
are all a part of her Legacy and that
includes me because that day in Eden
Court I got to sit in the front row and
ask the first Minister what she was
going to do to make sure that more women
and girls would enter politics in future
and it's a a question that's been
thoroughly answered since and I remember
her specific reply to me because she
said well Emma
I would like to see more young women
Emma making their voice heard Emma
and those words like me here and I think
that will be the same for other women in
this place both now and in the future
because I see little girls dressing up
as Nicola sturgeon for World Book Day
and I think the first Minister has very
safely achieved the goal that she set
out in her statement earlier she has
lifted and girls across Scotland are
rising to meet her and as one of those
girls I am confident that she will
continue to inspire no matter what she
does next
now presiding officer this has been a
personal contribution and but as I speak
on behalf of the SNP today I know that
we all want to thank her for her service
her selflessness and her dignity as
first Minister and I'm going to end just
by saying I've read quite a few books on
the the back of first Minister's
recommendations and I cannot wait to
read the books that Nicola sturgeon is
going to write thank you
thank you
and I call on Nicholas sturgeon first
minister
thank you presenting officer I am going
to be brief
firstly because I know everybody wants
to go and have lunch but secondly I'm
not sure that I can go much further
without crying so just to say for me to
colleagues across this chamber thank you
for your generous comments they mean a
great deal to me and I deeply appreciate
them
to Emma
am I remember that exchange uh really
well
and I cannot tell you how proud I am of
you that you know
sit in this Parliament making such a
positive contribution and who knows me
when they stand here at this place in
our Parliament thank you for that
contribution and Emma's is one of
probably thousands of interactions I've
had with girls and young women across
these eight years
of my team as first Minister and if I
have encouraged even just a few of them
to believe more in themselves and to
stand a bit taller then I will be very
happy because that means a great deal to
me more generally presenting officer to
lead this country is the Pinnacle of
what this shy
introverted that's still the case not
just when I was a young girl but what
this shy introverted working class girl
from Usher could ever have dreamed of
and this country is truly amazing and
the people who live in this country no
matter where they came from are also
amazing as I've traveled overseas as
first Minister and that has been an
enormous privilege I have had the
opportunity uh to see just how much
Scotland punches above her weight and I
have seen directly the respect that we
are held in by people right across the
globe perhaps all we need to do now here
at home is believe a bit more in
ourselves
now even although I know without a
shadow of a doubt that the time is right
for me to go I do feel emotional
today
and perhaps the reason for that is that
I know beyond doubt that even if I live
to be a hundred years old there is no
phase in my life that will be as special
or as meaningful to me as these last
eight years have been
you will of course see me very soon on a
back bench near here
but in the meantime presiding officer
for the final time for me as first
minister to the people of Scotland uh
thank you from the bottom of my heart
for the privilege of being your first
minister
thank you